did Nicki Minaj just make her
relationship Instagram official it sure
looks like it how the anaconda rapper
turned 36 over the weekend and gave fans
a glimpse of her birthday festivities
having some fun in the Sun and jet ski
with her crew but it was this snap that
sent Barb's into a frenzy Nicki cozying
up to Kenneth petty straddling what
appears to be her new beau captioned did
you ever make it out of that town where
nothing ever happens it's no secret that
the both of us are running out of
there's a lot to read in between the
lines here with the caption but nothing
has yet been confirmed by Nicki but
here's what we know about Kenneth fans
discovered unfortunately that he is a
registered sex offender in New York fans
are super fans and they will find out
your dirty business I know good this is
not good they're like the FBI they
really are so now fans are online with
an epic photoshop job literally cutting
Kenneth out of the picture replacing him
with Drake and Lewis Hamilton in
November they sparked romance rumors
after Nicki shared a pic of them hanging
out hmm and apparently outlets have
already reached out for Kenneth to have
an interview with them their interview
requests are going out how who I want to
watch that thanks for that first
interview Diggs was good
I'm doing that's not that's how you
begin car some of us might solo me
now despite kid it's past Nikki seems to
be smitten sharing several post on her
instace Tori looking happier than ever
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Chumley rapper has yet to confirm
that Kenneth is her boyfriend so let's
not get ahead of ourselves
no I stay right there but you know she
could still be saying yeah maybe she's
just dating mm-hmm
she has teased a little bit about her
love life while appearing on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show take a look there is new
boy right I I have my people there's a
new boy but he and I have kind of like
fell back a little bit and then and then
there's like the newer oh there's a
newer boy so there's a newer new boy
yeah how new is this new boy like barely
new as long as the hair has been on your
head no he's he's been around for a
couple weeks now
all right buddy I don't what I don't
have a boy Mickey has been linked to
Lewis Hamilton Drake which he shut down
that rumor and now Kenneth petty so on
Ellen she talked all about how she's
happier being single and said she
doesn't need a man because she's been in
long-term relationships since she was 15
she needs a break yeah Mickey spend some
time solo there's nothing better than
being single and getting to know
yourself and I think she's doing that
but Nicki of course has said she's also
dating she's having fun obviously we're
gonna keep our eye on this one with
Kenneth petty until next time I'm
Courtney underscore tezo no and I'm at
Halle underscore Stephens
you